the Prime Minister will deliver a stark
message to EU leaders when he makes his
first trip abroad as Prime Minister this
week he'll tell Angela Merkel Emmanuel
macron and others that they need to
strike a new deal or the UK will leave
on the 31st of October without an
agreement meanwhile more than 100 MPs
from all sides of the house have urged
the prime minister to recall Parliament
warning the country is on the brink of
an economic crisis for former brexit
Minister now Energy Minister glassy
quartz hang is here very good Minister
the Prime Minister is effectively saying
No Deal is unstoppable if we want that
to happen his knees have actually the
case what he's saying is that we're
going to leave with or without a deal on
the 31st of October and the reason he's
saying that is that this has gone on too
long it was actually the policy of the
previous government Teresa mais
government that no deal was better than
a bad deal and I heard her say that as
many people did hundreds of times and
we've got to deliver on that one way or
the other we're leaving the EU on the
31st of October and that's what the
government's focused on but the Prime
Minister's gone from saying it was a you
know a million to one chance that we
wouldn't get a deal to now being perhaps
some would say a little bit more
realistic about it is looking unlikely
it's lately you don't seem to want to be
playing ball well these things can
change very quickly and we've always
said that our first aim our preferred
outcome it's for a deal but if we don't
get a deal we have to be prepared to
leave without one and that's very clear
that was always been the policy of the
government even two or three years ago
when this whole process started we want
to get a deal but we should have been
prepared to leave without one but if we
do leave without one according to
operation yellow hammer hard border in
Northern Ireland shortages of food fuel
and medicines you know that does sound
pretty bad you've got to be honest I
think there's a lot of scare mongering
around and a lot of people are playing
into project fear and all the rest of it
we've got to prepare for No Deal in fact
the previous prime minister created Dec
sue and she said that the Mandate of
Dexy last year last summer was to
prepare for No Deal I was working in
that department that's what we were
focused on now we've got a new prime
minister who is very much focused on
and the scale and intensity of those
preparations are increasing and we will
be fully prepared to leave without a
deal on the 31st of October it's a case
of how you leave without a deal isn't it
MPs are trying to certainly somehow
peace I should try it right they're
trying to stop it Jena Miller has said
for her her response to her her legal
challenge is a pierogi Parliament she
says now cannot happen the government is
specified during that letter that's not
an option no we're not talking about
pierogi in Parliament I mean what people
are doing what their schemes they're
hatching and plots I don't know about
that what I do know is that the
Parliament voted overwhelmingly for the
referendum the Parliament voted pretty
overwhelmingly to trigger article 50 the
article 50 process is coming to an end
the 31st of October wasn't our date
it was the EU who set that date and
we're very committed to to leave by that
date and that seems perfectly logical to
me if the only option is to call the
general election prior you know sort of
campaigning is happening before the 31st
the election on the ID now the 1st of
November or whatever day that would be
and is that an option that actually
could be pursued that's something you
would support I don't think anyone is
talking about calling an election I mean
there's a lot of speculation about
things like a government of national
unity and all the rest of it I don't see
that as a way forward in order to have a
general election lots of things have to
happen which I think in my opinion are
unlikely to happen but we'll have to
wait and see but the main focus of this
government is to deliver the referendum
and to leave on the 31st of October if
Parliament when it comes back is there's
a vote of no confidence in Boris Johnson
and he loses there is some speculation
that he may not accept that vote you may
carry on is that a possibility well
there lots of ifs in this situation I
mean for a start it's not clear to me
that they will have a vote in their
confidence maybe they will and certainly
if that happens I don't think
necessarily the government is going to
lose that so there are lots of ifs and
hypotheticals here and I'm sure that the
Prime Minister will observe the letter
of the law what about plenty of your
colleagues 100 MPs from all sides of the
houses a substantial number have said
you know Parliament because of what is
going on Parliament needs to be recalled
now and to stay in place until brexit or
that date has been changed on
or whatever it may be isn't that a
sensible idea
well we voted on the recess that was
passed it was an all vote and also I
think that we've ample scope when
Parliament returns in September as
you've suggested there'll be lots of
debate they could well be a vote of
no-confidence as you said I don't know
but there were plenty of scope to debate
these issues fully when Parliament
resumes in September and look can we
move on to one or two other issues which
which are very much in in our minds at
the moment I want to start with PC
Andrew Harper because of that tragedy
this week and I think that has really
you know the public are very much in
shock as to losing a police officer
whilst on duty at the Home Secretary
talking about properly introducing a
police covenant now did that needs to be
done doesn't it in real terms I think I
think the circumstances of Andrew
Harper's death were appalling and
obviously people in the put in the
public why more widely are really
worried about the nature of crime the
nature of total disregard for police
officers and other people and I think
the Home Secretary's got the right
approach I think we have to look at
protecting our policemen who and women
who are at the front line and I think
the police covenant is a very good idea
I think we got a strong Home Secretary
who will always be on the side of the
victims as opposed to the criminals
there is of course this discussion I
mean the around the extra 20,000
officers an extra investment in the
police it's been welcomed on one hand
but there are plenty of people who've
said it's not really the right
investment in the right way when you
look at different levels of crime and
different types of crime in 2019 just
them need to be significantly more
investment than what we're seeing in
terms of 20,000 here look I think 20,000
is a start I mean whenever government
announces spending commitments people
will say it's not in our for it's not
applied it employed in the right way I
think 20,000 extra police officers is
exactly the right way to begin to try
and reassure the public and make the
public more safe so that they feel more
safe that's the important thing and I
think that yeah there are other ways of
policing there things like cyber crime
and
other other issues but we've invested in
those as well we've got some of the best
cybersecurity in the world but but in
making the public feel more safe is one
thing you also need to have a level of
respect for authority
respect for the police which seemed to
be lacking at the moment how'd you start
to rebuild that well you're quite right
I mean this is a cultural issue I mean
in terms of levels of respect for police
officers that's something which we have
to reverse in terms of the decline but
it's not something that can be done
overnight I think we've seen over the
last 10 20 years people being less
respectful not just a policeman just
starting around where people are saying
that we are in a more violent and
disrespectful age there's a lot of
debate about social causes of crime and
I think we should absolutely support the
police it'll take a while to get back to
the levels of deference that we saw in
the past but we can start now and I
think reassuring the public the 20,000
police officers is a good place to start
and in trying to make our streets safer
obviously there is this knife crime
there's some people calling it an
epidemic I don't know whether that is a
fair use of the term or not but it is
certainly very very problematic in
London and other parts of the country
now the Home Office launched this
chicken shop boxtroll campaign it's been
criticised of being amongst other things
borderline racist looking back now do
you have concerns about that campaign
not really I mean the important thing is
that people are dying people are getting
killed and the one responsibility that
government has is to make sure that that
goes down and it's dealt with rapidly
now if the best way to communicate the
message is the way that you described on
chicken boxes or what have you in
restaurants then we've got to pursue
that and this policy didn't come out of
the blue it's been road-tested there
were surveys done in terms of how young
people I think it's in between 10 year
olds and 21 year olds how young people
absorb messages and this was felt to be
an effective way to get the message
across and if that is so then we should
do that yeah it's just the world there
are people looking at this and saying
well you you're making assumptions about
particularly young black men but I don't
think going and what they're doing I
don't think these were assumptions I
mean there was there was actual
empirical evidence to suggest that this
was a good way of reaching people who
were affected by knife crime and in at
the end of the day it's those
10 to 21 year olds who are adversely
disproportionately affected by these
appalling crimes ok Minister very good
to torture this morning thank you very
much indeed